hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt heute gibt es mal wieder
einen klassiker von mir und zwar ist es
ein klassiker aus der familie
es gibt heute eine leckere diplomaten
torte und zwar ist es ein leckerer
lustiger teig und dann kommt da eine
sahne creme mit rein und ananasstückchen
und ein teil vom teig wieder noch
zerkrümelt und mit schokostreuseln
vermischt und kommt dann obendrauf
viele fragen mich jetzt wahrscheinlich
sowieso heißt diese torte diplomaten
torte aber ich kann euch die frage auch
ehrlich gesagt gar nicht beantworten
morath bei stufe vielleicht das weiß
auch mein mann nicht das heißt ihr seid
wieder gefragt kann er sein dass einer
von euch weiß wieso man die sind heute
diplomaten torte nennt bei uns geb ich
dir wie du wikipedia gucke ich
eigentlich nicht so genau ich frage mal
google oder murat die wir sind an mir
stadt jetzt mit dem rezept ich mache
jetzt den früher teig und ihr könnt mir
einfach mal sagen wieso man diese torte
so nennt so macht ist ich habe jetzt
bereits meine form vorbereitet und zwar
ist eine springform mit 24 zentimetern
durchmesser
da habe ich auf den boden etwas
backpapier gegeben und der rand ist
nicht eingefettet und führt diese form
brauchen wir dreier
100 g zucker
100 milliliter mineralwasser ich bin uns
noch etwas vanilleschoten extrakt des
steins ohne alkohol
dann habe ich hier hinten ein teelöffel
zimt einen teelöffel backpulver 80
milliliter öl geschmacksneutralen öl ich
habe zum sonnenblumenöl hier habe ich
100 gramm mehl und 100 gramm nüsse die
nüsse habe ich es selber fein gemahlen
einfach in meinem mixa und ich nehme
jetzt zuerst meine eier gibt die ihnen
die rührschüssel und gebt den zucker mit
dazu und lass das ganze jetzt einfach
mal schaue mich aufhören
und wenn die eier masse dann cremig ist
gebe ich jetzt noch vanille mit dazu ihr
könnt dann natürlich auch vanille zucker
oder ein bisserl vanilleschote mit dazu
geben aber ich finde dieses vanille ex
praktisch einfach viel aromatischer weil
es eben auch konzentriert ist
jetzt kommen die zwei flüssigkeiten dazu
öl und wasser
sie werden kurz ein niedriger stufe
untergerührt wir wollen jetzt die luft
aus dem teig nicht wieder ausschlagen
einfach nur ganz kurz
und jetzt gebe ich mein backpulver zum
mehl vermischt es ganz kurz
damit einfach keine klümpchen im teig
bildet gibt es jetzt auch hier mit dazu
und auch direkt die nüsse und das wird
jetzt auch noch ganz untergegangen zu
auf niedriger stufe
den rest mache ich jetzt per hand dafür
nimmt einfach den teig sauber und hebt
es hier kurz unter und so gebe ich den
teig in die vorbereitete form
und der teig wird jetzt bei 170 grad für
etwa 30 bis 40 minuten gebacken
ihr solltet auf jeden fall die stäbchen
probe machen und danach las ich den
kuchen komplett abkühlen
mein kuchen ist abgekühlt und ich kann
jetzt aus der form herauslösen und zwar
mache ich das einfach mit zu einem teig
habe dieser mira spielt da hinten mit
ihrem buch und ich nehme da immer ganz
gern sind aber dazu damit ich einfach
die springform nicht so seifer katze
oder gar nicht und stand nicht den teig
herausheben und jetzt nehme ich meine
torsten seeger als hilfe und teile den
boden ein und zwar muss unten jetzt
einen dicker boden noch stehen und oben
schneide ich so einen dünnen deckel ab
und es macht auch nichts wenn du jetzt
kaputt geht denn den zerkrümeln ich
gleich sowieso also meint auch noch ganz
frisch man könnte ihn jetzt erstmal so
eine stunde oder zwei stehen lassen da
kann man besser schneiden apa dass es
nicht schlimm
ihr seht auch da war gar nicht so ganz
oben aber das ist nicht schlimm wenn ich
nehme den oberen teil einfach weg
und stehen nämlich jetzt runter in
seiner schüssel rein schneidet aber doch
noch mal ein kleines stück weg das heißt
ich stelle mir das hier kurzum
die krümel die gebe ich jetzt hier
einfach noch in die schüssel mit ein und
setzt den kuchen jetzt auf eine platte
und cd unter jetzt ist backpapier der
kuchen chance so ziemlich empfindlich
weil er einfach schön luftig ist
deswegen muss man ein bisschen aufpassen
und jetzt setzt sich hier in den torten
rahmen außen rum und kann den jetzt
erstmal weg stellen und kümmere mich
jetzt erst mal um die kuchen krümmel
die muss ich jetzt nämlich schön
zerkrümeln ganz leicht also nicht zu
drücken sondern einfach nur zerreiben
und während samira hier jetzt noch ein
bisschen krümmel werde ich euch schon
mal die zutaten für die füllung zeigen
und zwar brauchen wir dafür 600
milliliter schlagsahne
ich nehme seiner fahrt zum steifen und
zwar sechs teelöffel hier habe ich
bereits abgetropft ein paar ananas
stücke also das war eine ananas zu ein
anderes mischung aus der dose dann
brauchen etwas puderzucker das sind 30
gramm und ich hab hier etwa 50 gramm
schokostreusel und die schokostreusel
gebe ich jetzt schon mal der samira die
kommen nämlich hier mit rein und die
jetzt einfach nur kurz verrühren okay es
war gar keine 50 gramm sondern 200
ich gebe jetzt meine sahne in meiner
rührschüssel und ich nehme jetzt hier
meine metallschüssel weil ich da einfach
ein spritzschutz drauf habe und gibt da
mein puderzucker mit dazu
und das lasse ich jetzt erstmal kurz
verrühren
und jetzt gebe ich hier durch die
öffnung mein sonderfahrt mit dazu und
lass die sahne steif schlagen
die sahne ist steif und jetzt gebe ich
etwa ein drittel der sahne auf dem
kuchen und verteilt es einfach so ein
bisschen
dann kommen da die ananas stücke drauf
und es ist auch so ein schöner kuchen
den man schon mal für den sonntag
vorbereiten kann dass ich so ein
sonntagskuchen der einfach auch der
ganzen familie schmeckt
und falls ihr keine ananas merkt könnt
ihr auch zum beispiel einfach kirschen
nehmen oder auch andere früchte
alles was ihr eben gerne habt aber ich
finde alles passt ihr richtig gut dazu
und jetzt bedecke ich das ganze mit der
restlichen sahne
und streicht es mit so einer winkel
palette glatt da geht es am einfachsten
können auch eine tankkarte nehmen
und jetzt bedecke ich die sahne noch mit
den streuseln
es war jetzt bisschen fehl
schokostreusel also eigentlich reichen
da auch 100 gramm aber ich glaub ich hab
da aus was ihnen irgendwie die komplette
packung reingelegt
und so gebe ich die torte jetzt erstmal
in den kühlschrank ich kann sie zwar
auch sofort an schneiden weil durch das
sander partisanen direkt fest wird aber
ich möchte trotzdem dass die torte gut
durch durch gekühlt ist weil sie so am
besten schmeckt klasse jetzt etwa eine
stunde im kühlschrank und dann schauen
wir uns gleich an wie sie aussieht und
natürlich wie sie schmeckt meine torte
sitzt gekühlt und ich kann jetzt hier
den torten rand abnehmen
den habe ich bereits mit einem messer so
ein bisschen gelöst und ich finde die
torte auch richtig hübsch zum angucken
natürlich bröselt jetzt ein bisschen
weil er oben die straßen streusel brösel
sind jetzt schneidet ihr mal andere
zeigt euch einfach das innere
wobei das innere genau so aussieht dass
äußern
der deal ist wahrlich nicht mehr so gut
aus weil dann echt bröselt aber das ist
einfach ein kuchen schmeckt richtig
lecker vielleicht falsch war gerade eine
stunde im kühlschrank
aber wenn man natürlich länger offen
stehen lässt auch über nacht wird dann
natürlich noch fester und weil mein mann
jetzt gerade so frech war probiere ich
jetzt einfach den kuchen
hu
ich bin diese nüsse mit den
schokostreuseln passen perfekt zu der
sahne und zu der ananas hast du dir das
gibt der torte so ein bisschen die säure
die sahne einfach so dieses cremige und
stern muss boden mit den sträußen ist
wirklich sehr locker und einfach
aromatisch oder wie sie stracciatella ja
genau hat auch was von stracciatella
weil jetzt nicht 600 gramm sahne nehmen
will kann zum beispiel auch die hälfte
davon durch quark ersetzen dann ist die
creme fester nicht mehr so locker
aber dadurch hat man einfach auch so ein
bisschen anderen geschmack also das wäre
auch was was ich auch gerne mal machen
würde weil man dann so ein bisschen
meine käse sahne hat aber das dürft ihr
einfach selber entscheiden
und vergesst nicht mehr zu schreiben
wieso diese torte diplomaten torte
heißen ich weiß es nicht aber es gibt
bestimmt jemanden der das weiß ich
bekomme immer gute tipps von euch und
mein rezept gibt es zum nachlesen auf
service - blog.de und ich freue mich
schon wieder aufs nächste mal und wir
sehen uns schon ganz bald
hmm